hey youtubers is Charlie so Disney's
gonna be bringing Star Wars rebels to
comic-con in a couple weeks so I wanted
to do a breakdown of the cast as well as
talk about how it's going to fit into
the new movie Canon normally my Star
Wars bonus videos are movie related but
there really isn't a whole lot going on
with Episode seven right now and they're
not gonna be bringing anything from that
to comic-con hello any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I'm gonna be doing Star Wars rebels
bonus videos until the series gets here
in the fall I will be doing episode
videos for that so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
it's basically gonna replace Legend of
Korra as the animated show that I do
videos for my channel since I also do
videos for the movies I just have one
giant playlist so I'll have a link to
that in the description too if you want
to watch other Star Wars related stuff
after this so the first big question
when can we watch episodes of rebels
they still haven't announced the
premiere date but they'll probably say
what it is during the comic-con panel
all we know is that it's coming in the
fall which means September or October
I'm betting on October just because most
TV shows in general debut between that
last week in September in the middle of
October so I'm actually not gonna be
going to that Star Wars rebels panel I'm
probably not gonna make it but I will be
doing a Star Wars theme to giveaway
during Comic Con remember I'm doing
giveaways for like all the types of
videos that I do on my channel so next
big question how do I enter the giveaway
and what do I win all the comic-con
giveaways I'm doing are gonna be the
same you can enter all of them if you
want all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
different videos that I post next week
just because I might not get another
Star Wars rebels video out next week I'm
gonna include this video so just leave
your comments on this video and it'll be
considered your entry in the Star Wars
giveaway I'm just picking one random
subscriber from the comments for each of
the giveaways I'll announce who the
winner is in about two weeks and it's
basically gonna be like a toy or an
action figure that you win yes the
giveaway is open to international people
but if you're international and you win
it'll probably be PayPal instead of like
an actual item so next big question
where does rebels fit in the new Star
Wars movie Canon in case you hadn't
heard this show is going to be canon so
the events that happen on the show
will affect what happens in the movies
like episode 7 8 & 9 that's in contrast
to most of the expanded universe stuff
which isn't considered canon anymore the
episodes will basically take place
between Episode three we're
to the sith in Episode four a new hope
it's actually closer to Episode four
picks up about five years before episode
four the interesting thing about that is
is that it means Luke Skywalker and Leia
are about eleven years old I'm just
getting that number because they're
twins and he was about 16 at the
beginning of episode 4 so you see what
they're doing they're planning for like
five seasons and at the end of that five
years you know one for each season
they're gonna start with the events of
Episode four so ideally you should
imagine the final moments of rebels
happening in the moments before Darth
Vader Star Destroyer chases Princess
Leia's Karelian Corvette into orbit of
Tatooine that actually kind of makes me
wonder if they're gonna open the series
with some similar imagery episode 7 is
also supposed to be starting on Tatooine
or at least the first parts of the movie
it's one of the first locations they
went to with the cast to shoot actual
footage it's almost like you can't do
Star Wars without going to Tatooine at
some point so really big question what
happens if rebels runs for like six or
seven seasons Clone Wars went for six
seasons so rebels could totally do the
same thing plus it's airing on a network
that Disney owns so it's cheaper for
Disney in the end they don't have to pay
licensing fees to Cartoon Network so
it's easier for them to keep the show in
production so if that ends up happening
where the show starts overlapping with
episode four they'll play just tell
their own unique stories and just kind
of reference stuff that's going on in
Episode four I know everyone's asking if
we're gonna see original trilogy
characters on the show the answer is yes
but not exactly the way you think I
think the biggest person that everyone's
been asking me about is actually a souca
from Clone Wars in case you forgot at
the end of Clone Wars season five
she left the Jedi Order and we didn't
see her again until she appeared in
season six you basically had a vision of
her dead in a potential future lying
next to mace windu it was just a vision
and creator Dave Filoni who's also
working on the rebels cartoon said that
he does want to include her somehow and
she be like in her 20s or 30s at this
point ashley eckstein the actress that
voiced her confirmed that she did
survive order 66
so ahsoka could totally show up plus
there's the whole force spirit twist
although I think if they do end up using
her she'll be flesh and blood ahsoka
James Arnold Taylor who did the voice of
obi-wan Kenobi in the Clone Wars is also
rumored to have some cameos so we could
see obi-wan to the other big confirmed
original cast member coming back is
Billy Dee Williams as Lando
so this is a huge deal and I'm super
happy that they actually got an original
trilogy cast member to come back and do
his character but Simon Kinberg who's
writing the series didn't really reveal
what Lando is gonna be doing on the new
series or how many episodes he's gonna
be in but probably to talk a little bit
about it during the Comic Con panel
they'll also probably announce which
other original cast members might make
an appearance Kinberg did tease that
there would be other movie actors coming
back to voice cameos but he didn't say
who I'm hoping since Mark Hamill is such
a prolific voice actor he comes back in
some way even if he's not doing Luke
Skywalker Harrison Ford and Carrie
Fisher aren't super huge on reprising
their roles and other non movie media
like on Family Guy Seth MacFarlane said
that whenever he did the Star Wars
parody episodes Carrie Fisher only
participated because she had already
played the Angela character and they put
Angela in the episodes otherwise she
wouldn't have done him the other
original trilogy character members that
I'm expecting to come back either might
be Anthony Daniels as c-3po or James
Earl Jones as Darth Vader although he
has said that he never wants to do Vader
again so I'm not planning on that Disney
hasn't really said Vader or no Vader but
he is supposed to have a small cameo the
main villain of the series is gonna be
the Inquisitor he's gonna be a force
sensitive Vader analog chasing down the
last of the Jedi he does have a
lightsaber in the promo pics but I don't
think he's a full-on Dark Jedi so the
show is called rebels and it's basically
about the creation or the initial days
of the Rebel Alliance in the timeline
the Rebel Alliance is more of an idea in
the heads of a bunch of troublemakers
and dissident politicians it's not so
much the giant fleet we see in the
original trilogy like in Return of the
Jedi the main cast is basically the
people they've already revealed the crew
of the ghost as well as the Inquisitor
and his team the ghost is a karelian vcx
100 modified freighter it's like a
smaller version of the Millennium Falcon
Disney really wants people to watch this
so they're promoting the hell out of it
which is really awesome
they have released details on all the
characters except the original trilogy
surprise cameos so the protagonists on
the show are basically like a prequel
version of Luke Skywalker's Millennium
Falcon team that we meet in Episode four
so here's a full breakdown of them
there's former Jedi kanan jarrus he's
being voiced by Freddie Prinze jr. think
of him as like a burnt out version of
Obi
Kenobi I say former Jedi because he's
obviously hiding out from the Empire and
he never completed his Jedi training
during episode 3 Revenge of the Sith
whenever order 66 went out he was still
a Padawan so he had never fully finished
his Jedi training he's a lot like Luke
during Empire Strikes Back you know he's
completed some training but he doesn't
have the maturity that a lot of Jedi get
from facing their ultimate challenge the
Inquisitor character is the main villain
he's gonna be voiced by Jason Isaacs at
least that's what IMDB says but the
casting could always change think of him
is like a dark version of Jedi Kanan
he's probably not a full Dark Jedi but
he does have a lightsaber I'm choosing
to think of him as like the Darth Vader
of the series even though Darth Vader
the actual character of my cameo if
you've already read any of the expanded
universe material the inquisitorial was
a branch of the Imperial intelligence
community led by force-sensitive
darkside agents they weren't full-on
Jedi but they did have the ability to
sense other force users which is part of
the reason the Emperor used them to hunt
down the Jedi because the expanded
universe is being tucked away in a small
Disney closet somewhere the show is just
simplifying things the Inquisitor will
probably be the only person that's part
of this branch of the Empire that just
has a team built around him they're just
calling him the Inquisitor for now but
they'll probably reveal his true name on
the show he is wearing Seth tech so I'm
curious to see how they explained the
rule of two and if he's Vader's
apprentice or the Emperor's so his hunt
for the Jedi is probably going to
intersect with the crew of the ghost
because of Jedi Kanan and their other
force sensitive character that's ezra
bridger he's being voiced by taylor gray
he's like a mixture of a young ahsoka
and luke skywalker he's got a sokka's
mouth but he looks more like Luke his
character it grew up in the Outer Rim
territories and he didn't have parents
oh he grew up on the streets and just
had to steal to survive and he's been
using the force to escape really
dangerous situations without knowing
about it the Outer Rim territories are
about as far as you can get from
Khorasan in the mapped galaxy if you
want to hide from the Empire they
probably will travel to a lot of
familiar planets on the show but because
they're trying to evade the Empire
they're plugin to spend a lot of time in
the Galactic rim jedi cannons gonna be
mentoring ezra and the ways of the Jedi
over the course of the show but remember
Kanan isn't a Jedi himself so I'm
interested to see if there's some
unintended consequences of that so the
next big character is hera syndulla and
she's that 12
like pilot and the owner of the ghost
she's being voiced by Vanessa Marshall I
guess you could say she's like the
scoundrel of the crew but she doesn't
come off as a dirtbag or anything I'm
gonna choose to think of her as the Han
Solo of the crew for now although she
doesn't embody all of Han Solo's
qualities supposedly she stole the ghost
so I'm wondering if they're paying
homage to the questionable ownership of
the Millennium Falcon
technically Han Solo wanted in a card
game from Lando fair and square but I
think it was implied that he may have
cheated Lando in that card game both
Lando and Han are cheats so you could
debate the cheating a cheater is fair
and square in addition to being the
pilot she's also supposed to be
mentoring the Mandalorian character
Sabine Wren she's being voiced by tiya
Sircar think of her is like the weapons
expert part of Chewbacca in the body of
a female humanoid they haven't revealed
a lot about the origins of her character
but remember a lot of what we know about
the Mandalorians comes from the expanded
universe so we could have to throw that
out there doing this weird graffiti
thing on the show where they tagged a
lot of stuff wherever they go with the
Rebel Alliance insignia
she's the graffiti artist I don't know
why they're making this a thing maybe
because they think little kids will
think graffiti is hip and edgy
I know we're all Star Wars fans here but
technically this is a show for children
on a children's network the next big
character Zeb is actually voiced by
Steve Blum you may remember him as the
voice of a mon on Legend of Korra or the
voice of spike on Cowboy Bebop
he's also voiced Wolverine in the x-men
cartoons he's like the real Chewbacca
the crew like the super big guy who's
just really tough his race is Lusa which
is actually something that they created
for rebels specifically it's not a race
that's been used in the Star Wars
universe before supposedly it's based on
the original Ralph McQuarrie designs for
Chewbacca and the wookie race the crew
also has a wisecracking astromech unit
his name is chopper he's gonna be like a
more sarcastic version of art too but
just like our - he's gonna be bailing
the crew of the ghost out of trouble on
a regular basis so the last character
and the newest one that they've
introduced is one of the villains his
name is agent Kallus he's gonna be
working with the Inquisitor he's gonna
be voiced by David Oyelowo so get really
excited because there's actually a
pretty big casting he doesn't have like
the Regal austerity of say Grand Moff
Tarkin so I'm gonna think of him is more
of like a young general veers
interesting fact Julian Glover played
beers in the original trilogy he's on
Game of Thrones right now playing
maester pycelle he was also in Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade as the main
villain there's supposed to be some
similarities between the agent Kallus
character and the Zeb character so I'm
wondering if they have some sort of
weird history but they might explain a
little bit more about that during
comic-con so that's basically it for the
show right now
they'll price screen some footage from
that first episode of comic-con
I'm pry not gonna make it to the panel
but if they do reveal anything big I'll
be sure to do a video my next Star Wars
bonus video is actually gonna be about
the characters from the expanded
universe that I want the show to bring
back be sure to subscribe to get it it's
actually a little bit easier for them to
bring people back on TV than it is in
the movies don't forget Star Wars
giveaway begins now and there's extra
linkage for my other Star Wars movie
videos in the description right now you
can click here to learn all about the
Jedi in the Sith in episode 7 and click
here to learn about the rest of the cast
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives